hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and.com and today we're going to
talk about potassium sparing diuretics
and as always whenever you get done
watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this medication so let's get started
as we've been going over these
medications in this pharmacology series
we have been remembering the word nurse
because this allows us to remember those
important concepts we need to know for
exams about these medications so first
we're going to start with the name the
name of the drug tells us how the
medication works which lays the
framework for understanding everything
else so we're dealing with potassium
sparing diuretics well that name right
off the bat tells us we're dealing with
a diuretic so we're going to be someway
altering how this nephron is dealing
with sodium and if we mess up how it's
dealing with sodium we can alter the way
the body's going to reabsorb water but
this sigh retic is potassium sparing so
it actually spares potassium compared to
those other diuretics we talked about in
this series like loop diuretics and
thiazide they wasted potassium so this
one's actually going to spare it so
let's talk about how it does that
well potassium sparing diuretics work to
inhibit the sodium and potassium
exchange that's occurring within these
cells that make up the distal parts of
the nephron and we're specifically
talking about the late parts of the
distal tubule and the collecting duct
and what it's going to do these
medications is it's going to affect the
sodium channels so to help us understand
how these medications are affecting the
sodium channels let's talk about our
nephron so if we're dealing with any
type of diuretic it's a really really
high probability that these diuretics
are going to somehow affect some
structure within this nephron like with
loop diuretics they affected loop of
Henle with the thiazide it affected the
early part of the distal convoluted
tubule
so our nephron just to recap there's
millions of these little structures
within your kidneys and they're like the
functional unit of the kidney because
they help our kidney
and produce urine so it starts up in
here in the glomerulus it's going to
filter your blood as blood is receive
and it's going to in a sense drip down
what it filters down into Bowman's
capsule and it's gonna start going
through the parts of the nephron and
each part of this nephron you can see
them in different colors we have the
proximal convoluted tubule the live of
Henle the distal convoluted tubule and
then the collecting duct each part is
really assigned its own role for
tweaking that filtrate so what's going
to happen to the filtrate hence what
will eventually become urine is that
it's either going to take ions and water
and put it back into the blood that's
what we call reabsorption or the blood
is going to secrete things it doesn't
really need into the filtrate so it can
be excreted that's like secretion or and
then eventually it's just going to leave
the body and be excreted as urine so in
a sense you're nephrons like maintaining
homeostasis of your fluid electrolytes
water and waste in the blood so how the
tascam sparing diuretics work is they
alter those sodium channels that make up
that late part of the nephron
specifically that late distal tubule and
the collecting duct and what they're
gonna do is they're gonna alter how
sodium is actually going to be
reabsorbed out of that filtrate to go
back into the blood and remember if
we're keeping more sodium in this
filtrate within that nephron which is
eventually going to become urine we're
gonna keep more water with it and that
will provide that diuretic effect so to
help us understand that a little bit
better and to be able to visualize it
let's look at that process of what's
happening with how like those ions
actually cross over from the filtrate to
go into the blood because that's the
process that these drugs are
manipulating so here we have an
illustration and this middle area
represented in pink represents like the
cells that make up the distal tubule and
the collecting duct and within these
cells you have to have these channels in
these pumps to facilitate the movement
of these ions so they can cross back and
forth over here represented in red
this red area this is our inner stitch
um slash blood and it has you know ions
and other substances hanging out in it
and some of those sentences want to get
over here to the filtrate and over here
in the orange that is represented with
our lumen the inside of that nephron
/the filtrate and again it also has ions
in it don't want to get over there to
the blood so to do that has to use those
channels and pumps one thing we want to
concentrate on is this sodium channel so
the sodium channel just like its name
says allow sodium to leave the filtrate
and go into the cell but once it's there
it needs to get into the blood stream so
in order to do that a sodium potassium
pump will help it do that so what that
this does is it takes the sodium pumps
it over there into the blood but it has
to exchange something for that sodium it
just put in there it has to take
potassium and hydrogen ions and move it
in the opposite direction and it will go
this way and this is occurring to allow
that to happen so we have sodium
channels and potassium sodium pumps
however whenever we throw on a potassium
sparing diuretic it's going to stop this
channel that sodium channel from doing
that so you're not gonna have sodium
leaving this filtrate going in over here
so more staying in the filtrate means
more water is gonna stay in the filtrate
we get that diuretic effect however it's
going to alter how this sodium potassium
pump works it doesn't have very much or
at all any sodium to pump over into the
blood so because it's not going to do
that it's not going to have the exchange
of the potassium leaving the blood along
with those hydrogen ions and going into
the filtrate so you're going to keep
more potassium in the blood hence its
potassium sparing so one thing I want
you to remember with potassium sparing
diuretics is that there when the directs
that keep potassium through that process
but patients can have hyperkalemia where
their blood level of potassium
is increase so remember that now there
are two different types of potassium
sparing diuretics they will all work
together to achieve these same results
but they will do it in different ways
with what they influence so the first
time I want to talk about are called
epithelial sodium channel inhibitors
these drugs directly inhibit this sodium
channel so by doing that it's going to
cause more sodium to stay in the
filtrate which will draw more water and
we'll have that diuretic effect but
it'll spare the potassium because we
didn't have that exchange with sodium
and potassium via that pump so there's
that risk of hyperkalemia and some drugs
that fall into this category of
potassium sparing diuretics are
triamterene and a miller ID and the
second group of potassium sparing
diuretics are called aldosterone
antagonists sometimes called aldosterone
receptor blockers and just as their name
says is that they antagonize aldosterone
so they're gonna work against the
effects that aldosterone would try to
create in your body now what does
aldosterone do normally aldosterone
causes your body to want to keep and
reabsorb the sodium and the water so
it'll tell that nephron hey I need you
to reabsorb sodium and water in exchange
for wasting potassium and hydrogen ions
and one way why your body would want to
do that is to help with blood pressure
management the blood pressure Falls to
low aldosterone can help increase blood
volume to help increase blood pressure
but how these drugs work is they tell
aldosterone no you're not going to do
this because our dosterone influences
the number of these sodium channels and
these sodium potassium pumps so if we're
limiting their number we're going to be
limiting how this whole process is
taking place so they have this same
effect like these direct epithelial
sodium channel inhibitors did with their
diuretic effects they're just doing it
under the influence of aldosterone and
these drugs include spironolactone
and Appler anon now let's talk about
what these medications are used for what
do they treat
well because potassium sparing diuretics
alter how we reabsorb sodium in water
they can be really beneficial in
treating high blood pressure
hypertension they can also help patients
who have excessive fluid volume where
they're having edema and swelling
related to like heart failure liver
impairment or maybe Neph rhotic syndrome
they can also treat hypokalemia where
you have a low potassium level in the
blood due to a side effect that's
related to maybe the patients on a loop
diuretic or thiazide so they may pick
them on a potassium sparing diuretic to
help prevent that and they can be used
to treat hyperaldosteronism specifically
the medications that antagonize
aldosterone and medication that's most
commonly prescribed for this is
spironolactone and with
hyperaldosteronism the adrenal glands
are producing too much i'll dosterone
and if we do that what's going to happen
we're going to be keeping lots of sodium
and water in our blood but we're gonna
be wasting lots of potassium so the
patient can have high blood pressure and
hypokalemia so we throw on this
aldosterone antagonist this is going to
help make it where we're not keeping so
much sodium and water so we can lower
the blood pressure and we won't be
wasting so much potassium so we can keep
our potassium levels stable now one
thing I want to point out about
potassium sparing diuretics is that they
tend to be the weakest in there diuretic
affects compared to the other drugs that
are diuretics like loop diuretics and
thigh azides because they don't have
such a profound effect on how we're
dealing with decreasing sodium
reabsorption like with loop diuretics
those are very powerful because they're
dealing with a part of the nephron that
really plays a huge role in reabsorbing
loss of sodium this isn't really the
case with potassium sparing diuretics
which is why a lot of times potassium
sparing diuretics will be combined with
either like a loop diuretic or a
thiazide
now let's wrap up this lecture and let's
talk about the nurse's role the side
effects and education pieces for the
patient who may be taking a potassium
sparing diuretic so we have learned that
these medications are going to increase
urination because they're altering how
we're reabsorbing sodium which hence
affects how we're going to deal with
water so because they're going to be
urinating out more fluid they're at risk
for dehydration so as a nurse we have to
watch out for that how can we tell our
patient is dehydrated well we can look
at their vital signs house their blood
pressure if their systolic is less than
90 that tells us that we've depleted
their fluid volume a little bit too much
or how's their heart rate is it
increased where the body is trying to
compensate for that low blood pressure
anything greater than 100 their attack
of Kartik how's your patient acting are
they
really thirsty or they fatigued they
have mental status changes this could
indicate that they are dehydrated
because of those signs and symptoms and
you want to teach the patient how to
identify that that's happening to them
at home and to report that to their
physician also we want to monitor their
intake in their output we want to make
sure that they're not putting out so
much fluid compared to how much they're
taking in because we don't want to
dehydrate them plus we want to look at
their renal function that'd be you in
and creatinine that tells us how well
our kidneys are really working to filter
our blood and if we dehydrate them too
much we can cause some renal issues and
potassium sparing diuretics are not for
patients who have renal failure another
they were watching out for our
electrolyte imbalances and what was the
big electrolyte imbalance I told you to
watch out for is hyperkalemia because
these medications spare potassium so a
normal potassium level that you
definitely want to put in your memory is
three point five two five millionths per
leader so anything greater than five
we're getting in hyper Kaleem 'ya
territory so what are some signs and
symptoms that your patient's potassium
level may be high without really even
looking at the lab result well you want
to make sure you're looking at their
EKG how do their tea waves look if
they're tall and peaked that could be an
indication that they're in hyperkalemia
remember that that's a big test question
that they'd like to ask about fluid in
electrolytes also how's your patient
reacting are they reporting muscle
cramps muscle weakness
are they having difficulty breathing or
do they have paresthesia where their
skin feels like it's tingling and
burning they're nauseous or vomiting
also teach the patient to recognize
these signs and symptoms as well of
course they can't recognize the tall
peaked t-waves
because I don't have an EKG monitor at
home but teach them these other things
also you want to teach your patient to
avoid foods high in potassium because
we're already keeping potassium we don't
want them to just go and eat lots of
food rich in potassium so to help you
remember foods that are high in
potassium remember the word potassium
and this includes foods like potatoes
and pork oranges tomatoes avocados
strawberries spinach fish mushrooms and
musk melons like cantaloupe in addition
you want to tell your patient to avoid
those salt substitutes because those
actually contain potassium and many
patients who are taking potassium
sparing diuretics may be taking it for a
heart condition like heart failure or
high blood pressure and they've been
educated watch your salt watch your salt
so they may use a salt substitute not
knowing that it's really high in
potassium so educate them about that as
well
now some medication interactions that
you definitely want to watch out for
again like I said patients who are
taking potassium sparing diuretics may
have heart failure so they may need to
be taking an ACE inhibitor an ARB and
those medications can increase potassium
as well we talked in depth for why that
was if you want to check out those
videos so you want to be watching that
looking at the potassium level looking
for those signs and symptoms hey the
potassium level may be high also NSAIDs
can cause that as well they're taking
something for pain that can increase
potassium levels and lastly another
thing is about drug wise is
em because we're altering how the
nephron is working and reabsorbing and
excreting and everything we can alter
how the body can actually clear lithium
where it could actually build up in the
system so the patient's lithium levels
would need to be monitored closely
because they're at risk for lithium
toxicity in a normal lithium drug level
that you want to remember is 0.5 to 1.2
millimoles per liter so anything greater
than that there is a risk of lithium
toxicity and some miscellaneous side
effects that you want to remember as a
nurse so you can teach your patient is
that some of these medications can upset
the stomach so they may want to take
this medication with food or right after
they have a meal to help decrease those
signs and symptoms and these medications
can produce an anti-androgen effect and
we're mainly talking about those
aldosterone antagonists specifically
spironolactone because this medication
affects the androgen and progesterone
receptors so some patients may
experience gynecomastia minstrel
problems and sexual dysfunction okay so
that wraps up this review over potassium
sparing diuretics